the Joe Rogan experience - Bronson let's
eat smoked one two three four five six
seven blunts in the course of one
podcast he had one in his hand I think
that's right that's crazy he went hard
he just keeps going I don't have the
weed tolerance like I have the booze
tolerance how do you feel about spliffs
in here you love them you do you Gary we
have a fan we have this room is set up
for smell you feel bad smell got blown
over he's gonna turn the fan on it'll
suck all the air out of the room and
connect us with Jesus look at that Wow
yeah we set it up well we built this
room we had it set it up for Dice Clay
smoke and I would never want to tell him
not to smoke so I bought because I'm
just happy he's here so I bought him I
bought an air machine oh my god process
to air while he was this free that's
that's stanhope use that I was like
perfect all right now we got one for
smokers so fire up that spliff kind sir
do not be scared all right young Jamie's
impervious to all forms of intoxication
he's probably from another planet he's a
thousand milligrams of THC no line why
and I'm like how are you he's like I'm
fine twelve fifty excuse me pardon me I
have insulted Mary Jesus from afar yeah
1250 I'm impressed
I'm very impressed he's an alien and
also inspired well you know like sheep
can't eat like a certain grass and
they'll die to eat phalaris grab the
[ __ ] DMT killer I did not know that
yeah you can take it it's a part of your
brain but if a sheep gets all of it like
they just died
legs sticking up near twitching it turns
out they had a day
DMT rich concentrated patch of grass
gills of dead in their tracks like
farmers in certain areas would find
these sheep like legs no way yeah the
last time I smoked DMT I was in the
bathtub and I was you know prepared to
have a moment and I got myself all
situated and I like lit up and then I
hear like and I'm like I get up and I
put a robe on and I go to the front door
and my old landlord Carlos was like me
Suzie Suzie the ceiling is leaking and
my bathtub was leaking and I was you
didn't know no and I was very high it
was a terrifying experience
oh my god your DMT I see you pixelated
in Show and PS though it was kind of old
so I didn't get as like you didn't get a
solid no but I got enough of a head to
be [ __ ] up with my landlord knocking
on my door when I was a little high on
DMT so anyway I haven't smoked it since
I'd like to at some point but Duncan
Trussell
[Music]
wouldn't I call Joe Rogan - I'm with you
guys they should be they should be
they're missing the point
well this like the drug users versus
[ __ ] law enforcement you guys should
be on drugs you want to do good law
enforcement she all be on mushrooms
that's what we should have every cop on
mushrooms like like he'll know which
just run up on them you know that guys
these dad's in prison right now that
guys dad's a bank robber
I think all cops see Andrew yang had a
great idea is all cops should be purple
belts and jiu-jitsu which I really I
agree with I think it's a great idea
so you should have some understanding of
how to defend yourself if someone tries
to grab you and get your gun I 100%
agree with that but also why not be on
mushrooms to their life and death in the
streets teach people the right way
together I agree I'll be a part of love
yeah it's I think it's possible yeah I
think we just need to adjust the
chemicals that we have just like you've
done with exercise and some people done
with medication or meditation and
medication some people do with music it
adjusts the chemicals and I think that's
I think every way that we know of that's
beneficial to adjust the chemicals
whether it's through yoga or meditation
or love or music or comedy or anything
you can find that puts you in a better
place we should embrace that and agree
mushrooms are one of those things I
agree it's not it's you shouldn't listen
to a CD highway to hell all day long
ac/dc highway to hell 24/7 is gonna be a
bummer man I mean you might you might
like the first two or three plays
right you know it's like Billy Squier
lonely is the night you don't want to
hear it every day mmm but every now and
then when you're in a car you know how
you have that Bluetooth thing that
happens when your car synced up to
bluetooth yeah does your car do that do
the Bluetooth where like randomly to
play a song yeah it's always all no not
alt-j we goes through the a and yeah a
lot of Titans I told Tommy Segura that
what there was one of his bits would
come up like one of the first things
well it's any but sometimes it's a
random thing to it sometimes it doesn't
do it alphabetically it just doesn't
randomly and like you'll get like a cool
song out of nowhere just plays when you
start your car like oh that's a drunk
it's a little weird drug yeah yeah what
you guys do is a little weird drug
likewise so are we drug dealers is that
what you're saying that's a good way
we're like the proverbial I love
whenever you could use proverbial we
should be wearing robes
[Applause]